Let's at the Joe Rogan experience.
That's kind of like the the what is it?
The uh,
the,
the staircase,
you know that documentary where like two of his wives died falling downstairs.
Oh yeah.
That's,
people are like,
what?
You still don't fucking know.
You think two women coincidentally,
imagine if they did.
They're your favorite people ever and they just kept falling.
Can pop it literally impossible.
What if you're a rock climber there?
It was in his kitchen.
Is it is fucking kitchen?
Did he tries to like an owl did it?
What's this
crazy dude he had fucker.
Now he had such influence.
He said a bluebird flew in and scared her and flew out of the home because there
was no fucking bird by the way.
But he said a bird flu in scared her and she fell down the stairs backwards.
By the way,
you know how hard it is to fall back down the stairs backwards when you,
when you're already at the top of the stairs,
nobody falls backwards when they're walking upstairs.
Kicked Sparta.
Someone has to hit you down the that's exactly.
The lawyer was like,
somebody pushed you down the stairs.
That's the only way that happens.
Sparta.
Sparta,
fuck you.
If they did an autopsy and they see the footprint right in the middle of her
chest.
Well they said the blood splatter was like so obviously consistent with someone
that was like thrown downstairs.
Yeah.
He's,
Oh god,
her bro and these huddles are doing that.
That is a thing that happens.
I'll fly into your home.
They fuck shit up.
They're not good guests.
They're not nice people.
Assholes.
Yeah.
They really are truly not nice birds.
There's such a cool animal.
Yeah,
they are.
They're a weird animal that we like.
Think of them as these wise old creatures.
Like we,
we,
we have like an anthropomorphic version of an owl that's really smart.
Like an owl is like,
hmm.
Well yeah,
like the read off and find out what's going on in pop out.
You know,
how many licks does it take?
That was like,
he wore glasses too.
Yeah.
Well that must be what it is.
But the wise old owl is like an adage,
right?
Yeah.
Why is it though?
I don't know man.
Because they're fucking ruthless.
What they are is just cunts that swooped down and kill rabbits.
They fuck rabbits up man.
They're wingspans are fucking incredible.
When you see them take off,
take flight and come snag something.
It's,
it's wild to see driving home once and one was flying over my head and I guess
it didn't like how low it was as to where my car was on the road.
Like it picked a path probably not in its head understanding that cars go down
this road.
It was flying.
Right,
right.
And the car was just too close.
So we just dropped the rabbit and went to get it later.
And uh,
I pulled over cause they're like,
what the fuck was that?
Because it was big,
like whatever it dropped,
it was a fairly large creature and a,
I went over in this rabbit that was just gutted because the first thing they eat
is the guts.
So to just torn the guts out of this rabbit.
They pick it apart and then they take the rest home with them.
They swooped down.
Have you ever seen a,
an OWL's clause?
Yeah,
they're fucking nasty.
They're huge.
Giant has clause that the coolest video.
Look at that thing.
Look at the clause that they're bad ass dude.
Oh my God.
It's an amazing first one.
Predator.
The first picture looks like him saying,
don't take a picture.
And then the second one,
he's like,
you,
why did you take the fucking,
I told you not to make the pitch.
Yeah.
It's like mad at you and she's picking it up.
Look at the eyes in that thing,
man.
I mean,
it has a demonic face that's like beautiful Predator man.
It's an incredible animal.
Um,
but there's that one.
There's an amazing video online of one killing the hawk.
It kills a hawk in its,
in its nest.
It swoops down in the night.
They got a trail camera,
Frodo.
They had these,
this,
these hawks that were in this nest and these a wildlife biologists were filming
it and this,
this egg,
this owl will comes in and watch this and just snatches the Hawk right from the
nest watch test.
Here comes in the distance.
You'll see it's a little eyes any second now.
It's crazy shit to watch the little baby Haka.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
A little baby.
Look at that.
Watch this motherfucker come in and look at this like,
Oh shit bitch.
Whoa.
Fuck.
That's a wrap son to snatched it.
Okay.
The mom.
I was like,
what happened?
What happened?
I don't even know if that's a mom.
That might also be another baby.
It's pretty big though.
Yeah.
It's hard to tell.
It's hard to tell because we remember prospective,
but look at this.
Look how it snatches it
just to hang out.
Look all the feathers of fly off.
Two hands grabbing a hold.
I don't know why that freaks me out so much now.
That freaks me the fuck out.
Bird on bird violence is weird.
Crazy to do.
It is bird lives matter man.
But it's bird on bird violence is strange cause it's almost like a cannibalism.
It's,
it happens so often is Jack Birds.
Cause they don't give a fuck.
It doesn't matter if they don't give a fuck.
But do you think that's a last resort?
Kind of.
They don't really want to eat other birds,
right,
bro?
Everybody eats birds or the next picture.
Even birds.
That's a bird swallowing chick.
Yeah.
They'll get it.
Look at it bucking and it's his throat.
Fuck what a Twat duck.
Yeah.
That's a fucking whole duck.
That's huge.
Yeah.
Look at that thing.
That is huge.
Well that's a chick.
It's not a fully grown duck but,
but it's big.
It's big enough that it's crazy that that thing swallows it.
You know the one of the really fucked up ones and I saw recently I saw a toad
eat a rat or a mouse a want to see that your mouse?
Yeah.
It's either frog or a toad.
I don't know what it was.
But a big ass green frog looking type creature swallowed a mouse hole.
Watch this.
This is it.
Yeah.
This is crazy,
dude.
Oh this is not,
it does not it because this one's hidden.
There's one that's not hidden.
There's one where you could see it like in like a little glass container.
Damn.
I wish I could find it.
Um,
cause it's a really good one.
It's from like a top down view.
That's pretty good.
Watch this.
I didn't think that frogs ate mice,
man.
I used to think the frogs are like,
oh,
you know,
they just get bugs,
bugs out of the air.
Watch.
He's just not yet.
Not yet.
I want to make sure I get them.
Make sure you let him sniff around.
Oh,
you closed.
Maybe move a little bit of a move.
I'm on you.
And as soon as I decide you're lined up,
fuck you.
Look at that head first.
Just delete it.
Stuffing it in there with his greasy little fingers.
I mean,
think about what a pro,
get the mouse trying to get out.
The mouse is trying to get out because they don't have teeth,
right?
So they just got to get out.
Its head is out,
man.
Look,
it's eating it,
asshole first.
Jesus Christ.
The mouse was like,
let me just let me,
I'm just curious me.
But I eat the butthole first cause that's the worst taste.
So Ethan,
I don't forget the bad taste out of how they're thinking.
That's just where it was.
I think it would have eaten it headfirst too.
But look at it.
It's just blinking.
Slowly swallowing the mouse.
Imagine you being able to eat a dog.
That's what that's like.
The size difference.
That's like you eating a German shepherd,
German shepherd,
just stuffing anymore face.
Dislocating my jaw,
putting it in.
How big is the frog's mouth?
That's crazy.
That's,
I guess,
what do you see those things that can dislocate their jaws?
I think that's incredible.
Animals that can fucking unhinge their job.
Snakes.
The snakes here.
That shit.
Yeah.